حرق المصحف امام السفارة التركية
في ستوكهولم هو فعل قبيح ولا
شئت يا مورافسكي. خلال ذلك اعلنت
شركة الرايمونتال الالمانية
وها هو قائد جيش الجزائر السعيد
شنقريحة يتوجه الى فرنسا بزيارة
وماذا عن تركيا يا هؤلاء?
التحركات الجزائرية لا تتوقف?
بين البلدين خاصة في مجال الطاقة
ليكشف مسؤول ايطالي عن تحركات
بلاده لتكون مركزا للغاز في
اوروبا. فهل تكمل الجزائر
جمائلها مع ايطاليا بجعلها مركزا
لسد مجاعة الطاقة الاوروبية?
الجزائر تتلاعب باعصاب الغرب.
الجزائر صارت محط انظار دول
اجراءات ضد متطرفين. لكن حلف
الناتو لا يرى ان حرق كتاب
سردين الايطالية من خلال خط تحت
الماء يربط ميناء كودية الدراوش
اللجوء. شركة جوجل تسرح ستة في
المائة من موظفيها عبر العالم
الجزائري بميناء بورتو بوتي في
جنوب غرب سردين. بينما وقعت
الايطالية للجزائر فهي جورجيا
ميلوني تعود محملة الجزائري.
استعدادها تسليم اكثر من مائة
دبابة الى اوكرانيا اذا استلزم
منا دعم فيما يتعلق بعضويتكم في
الناتو. ليضيف اردوجان ان واقعة
والحكومات في الحرب الروسية
الاوكرانية. فما الذي ستنتج عنه
من اجل زيارات عمل كلفتهم بها
الحكومة. لكن التقارير الغربية
بي اي. لتعلن واشنطن مؤخرا عن
اعتقال مسؤول سابق في الاف بي اي
الحرب? يا له من منطق. رئيس
وزراء بولندا ماتيوس مورافسكي ان
الخسائر الكبيرة. واضافت الهيئة
ان قواتها الجوية شنت ثماني
اوروبا التي تعاني من ازمات لا
تحصى وبعد زيارة لرئيسة الوزراء
العقوبات على اصحابها كالعادة?
بينما التناقض الغربي. وعلى لسان
فضيحة مدوية. تغيير التكتيكات.
بعد عام على الحرب تغيرت امور
رسمية بعد دعوة وجهها له نظيره
الفرنسي بوكاغ في زيارة هي
بولندا هذه المنظومات بالقرب من
الحدود الاوكرانية. والحرب ها هي
وليس عسرا يا هؤلاء. تتغير
التكتيكات وتتبدل الاحوال
هذا الاطار اذا? لينضم الاتحاد
الاوروبي الى القائمة بفرضه حزمة
الاولى منذ عشر عاما. فهل تنال
باريس هدية جزائرية على طريقة
الاحداث وباتت تركيا في موقف صعب
بين دينها وحلفائها. بعد ان كانت
تعليم للمرأة ولا سينما ولا خروج
الا بالنقاب الافغاني. الدين يسر
واسقطت ثلاث مسيارات. ومن الحروب
اللوجستية الى الحرب الجاسوسية.
اعلنها الرئيس التركي اردوغان
للسويديين قايلا اذا كنتم لا
التغييرات الى حزم العقوبات. هنا
تعلن بلجيكا انها جمدت اصولا
لتأخذ الحرب منعرجا اخر. وها هو
رئيس الاركان الروسي الجديد يؤكد
لانضمام السويد وذلك بحسب وكالة.
وكالة ذاتها هي من اعلنت ان
وزير الدفاع الالماني الذي قال
ان حلف الناتو يجب الا يكون طرفا
لكن ذلك يحتاج لاطار قانوني وهو
غير متوفر حتى الان. فكيف سيتوفر
ليضع البلدان الية لتنفيذ خط
انابيب لنقل الغاز الجزائري الى
لا يتمنى الغرب ان تصل ليده
والحكومة البريطانية تصحو على
حيث اخترقت موسكو اقوى جهاز
استخبارات في العالم. نعم انه اف
ان الرئيس بوتين وافق على
الاصلاحات الجديدة في الجيش
العقوبات المفروضة على موسكو
وذلك بحسب شبكة ام بي سي. هاي.
الاوكرانية عزل مسؤولين ووزراء
وكذلك رؤساء اقاليم دينيبر
اتفقنا مع على استمرار التواصل
كما كان بالسابق. يا لها من
يمل عن هجماته. ليطلب المسؤولون
الامريكيون من اوكرانيا تغيير
تكتيكيا في باخموت بدلا عن حرب
الاستنزاف هنا والتركيز على جبهة
دبابات الالمانية الى اوكرانيا
فلتصل الدبابات اولا ثم اطلب ما
خيانة مضحكة. هل تنضم فنلندا
للناتو وتبقى السويد بدون حلفاء?
السنوي اليوم ام ماذا? هناك جاب
الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي انهم يجرون
انقرة اكثر. فما الذي يجري؟
وبوتين يوجه بطرد السفير
يمتلك اي شخص حرية اهانة مقدسات
المسلمين او الاديان الاخرى. حتى
في الحرب في اوكرانيا مؤكدا ان
بلاده جهزت حزمة جديدة من
وزبروجيا وسومي وخرسون والعاصمة
كييف بحسب وكالة الانباء
ولكن لا ننسى ان بوتين خدم
كجاسوس سوفيتي بالمانيا. وهذه
فنلندا تدير ظهرها للسويد. حيث
قال وزير خارجية فنلندا وعلينا
الجزائر خمس مذكرات تفاهم جديدة
مع ايطاليا تستهدف زيادة التعاون
ان موسكو ايدت كلام اردوجان
لتصريح الخارجية الروسية انها
الشريف. والجزائر تكرم ايطاليا
لتكون محطة تجمع الاوروبيين لسد
اقالة كبار المسئولين في الدولة.
موسكو تضع الاف بي اي بموقف محرج
بشكل جماعي وفوري يبلغ عدد اثني
عشر الفا. وفي افغانستان لا
تغييرات في المناصب على مختلف
المستويات للحكومة والاقاليم
انقرة قريبة من الموافقة على
انضمام السويد لحلف الناتو
كشف صحيفة الجارديان عن اختفاء
غامض بحوالي مائتي طفل من طالبي
روما? الاحداث والتطورات. فضيحة
مدوية للحكومة البريطانية بعد
كثيرة واوكرانيا تعاني الويلات
يا سادة والدب الروسي لا يكل ولا
المساعدات العسكرية لاوكرانيا
بقيمة مليار وثلاثمائة مليون
هويته التي تم تسريبها. ولهذا
تخافه الكثير من الدول. فلكل
جوعهم للطاقة. والصين تضع الملح
في جروح الامريكان. وتبعث لبوتين
واوروبا تنفس عن غضبها بحزمة
عاشرة من العقوبات ضد روسيا
للنايتو. فنلندا تدير ظهرها
للسويد من اجل الناتو وتتقرب من
ان ندرس احتمال الانضمام الى حلف
شمال الاطلسي بدون السويد.
المسلمين المقدس قضية تستدعي
موقف الرئيس التركي المعرقل
تحترمون المعتقدات الدينية
لتركيا او المسلمين فلا تنتظروا
تدين وترفض مثل هذه الاعمال
الاجرامية وتدعو الى اتخاذ
الامر. وبالعودة للحرب فقد
اعترفت هيئة الاركان الاوكرانية
ان القوات الروسية تتقدم في
محوري باخموت وابدي اذكر رغم
وارسو ستطلب من الاتحاد الاوروبي
تعويضا مقابل تكلفة ارسالها
بتهمة انتهاك العقوبات الروسية
وذلك بتبييض الاموال وانتهاك
وهذا مؤشر بوجود ثغرات في
العقوبات السابقة. فهل تعود
الحدود مع فنلندا لمواجهة
الناتو. بينما اعلنت الخارجية
غارات على مواقع تمركز القوات
الروسية داخل الاراضي الاوكرانية
يورو. ليتسائل الروس هناك وهل من
يقدم مساعدات عسكرية ليس طرفا في
الروسية عن طرد السفير الاستوري
في موسكو وتخفيض العلاقات
روسية ضخمة من اجل تحويل هذه
الاصول لاعادة اعمار اوكرانيا.
الحزمة تشمل محاولة بعض الدول
التحايل على العقوبات ضد روسيا.
عاشرة من العقوبات ستخضع لها
موسكو بهدف عزل روسيا. لكن
تقترب من الخروج عن حدود
اوكرانيا يا سادة. ومن حرب
اكد ان اقالة مسؤولين بارزين في
اوكرانيا جاء على خلفية فضائح
وهمية. وهل هذا وقت الفسادية?
هؤلاء التغييرات وصلت روسيا ايضا
انطلقت قافلة للجيش الالماني تقل
اول دفعتين من دفعات صواريخ
ليضيف الرئيس الروسي عسكريا الى
كاريليا في شمال روسيا على
فساد في اوكرانيا تتعلق بمعدات
الجيش وشراء الاسلحة باثمان
الدبلوماسية بين البلدين متهمة
تالين بالعداء لروسيا هناك
باتريوت الثلاث التي وعدت
المانيا ديميا الى بولندا. لتنشر
وانه لن يكون بمقدور المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين مغادرة البلاد الا
دولة صمت اسود في خزانته. انقرة
ترد على السويد بقوة. اشتعلت
في التكتيكات العسكرية
والميدانية فقط. هل ذكرت جردك
الاوكرانية. فلما كل هذه
التغييرات يا هذا? وقد طلب منك
لكن اين? نعم لقد جاءت في صلب
الحكومة لتعلن الرئاسة
الاستوني على وجه السرعة. وتصريح
روسي شديد اللهجة ضد حرق المصحف
الجنوب بحسب شبكة سي ان ان.
التغييرات الاوكرانية جاءت فورا
هذه التغييرات برأيكم?
واردوغان للسويد. سنجعل بوتين
يداعبكم وانسوا حلم انضمامكم
لقد تركوني وحيدا لقد خانني اقرب
الاشخاص الي. هكذا قالها
وبنك الاهداف مفتوح.
زيلينسكي لتمطر بعدها الحكومة
الاوكرانية قرارات حاسمة تتضمن
انا تحدثت كثيرا وقلت الخيار
النووي موجود على الطاولة. اذا
نعم. سيكون الرد الروسي يحمل شيء
من القسوة ودائرة الاهداف واسعة